as I mentioned you will need to define
the design challenge before the design
sprint to help you decide on the design
challenge here are some things that you
can do first you should interview key
stakeholders stakeholders can be
investors designers or engineers they
could also be someone like the user or
anyone else related to the product
second you should identify or review any
of the use cases for the product next
you should review all relevant user
research and finally you should review
any current designs that you have on the
product if you're planning your first
design sprint it's likely that you will
not have any current designs in that
case you should focus on these first
three tasks when going about the design
sprint at Udacity
we recently plan to design sprints the
first design challenge involved
redesigning the entire user journey
through a nano degree from the time a
user hears about a nano degree the time
that that user graduates and advances
their career or lands a new job a second
design sprint focused on one particular
part of our user journey we started to
think about how to redesign student
support through forums code reviews and
other methods you'll need to plan a
specific design challenge like these for
your own product and it's likely that it
will be for the main user journey
navigation and key tasks that users will
perform the design challenge statement
is what you need to actually write and
it creates a single focus for what is
the output of the design sprint a good
challenge statement should have a couple
key qualities first it should be
relevant to the highest priority work of
the team and it should be tied to a
purpose or a key result it should also
be concise and to the point and
hopefully inspiring for yourself the
design challenge statement should also
include a target audience or segments of
the audience and finally for projects
that are in progress you'll want to
include a launch time stated in terms of
years or quarters so would you want to
be launching in q1 q2 q3 or q4
your design challenge statement will
identify the tangible items that you
want to have at the end of the design
sprint and at the least it should answer
one of two questions what are you
missing that you need critically or what
is the riskiest
decision or hypothesis that you want to
test with your users you can use a gap
analysis like this one to determine what
the product is missing or what's one of
the riskier decisions or hypotheses that
you need to test this checklist is
linked in the instructor notes here's
one example of a challenge statement you
might design a mobile app that helps a
visitor plan and find the most relevant
personalized and exciting activities to
do in a city keeping in mind that the
visitor only has it one day for their
visit the deliverables in this case
would be to get wireframes sketches for
ideas that would be implemented in q3 of
2015 your design challenge statement
should be similar and have components
like the what of the deliverable the
timeframe for when you need it by and
also a clear user with what they'll be
doing in the application or the product
now the goal for your first sprint will
likely to be to map up the basics of
your new website or app including some
flows pages or screens and the basic
navigation now that you know about a
challenge statement I'd like you to
think about one for your own design
sprint what would you create and for
what kind of users and by when would you
create it and in order to do what take a
minute to think about this and then
write your answer in the box below don't
feel like you need to commit to this one
design sprint challenge for your own
design spring you could actually change
this later and your final project